[Music]
supermodel ashley graham has made it her
mission to change the fashion industry
and make it more inclusive and she's
doing that
first on cbs this morning we are
revealing her new cover photo
for the wall street journal magazine wow
and wow her photo shoot and cover story
are being released online today
and in the article graham discusses
becoming a champion
for models of all sizes she also opens
up about balancing motherhood and her
multifaceted career made the pandemic
ashley graham joins us now ashley good
to see you again i love the uh
the cover the headline of your story on
the inside it says
the beauty of being ashley graham i'm
thinking it's pretty good to be you
these days
isaiah's mom bank scale so they were
talking oh
thank you i knew you'd like that they
were talking about the uh
the difference in this shoot what makes
this shoot so unique for this particular
cover what'd you do
well being a part of the wall street
journal magazine cover is a dream come
true it's such an
honor and i feel like this cover and the
story and the pictures are real
representation of my last 21 years in
the industry
we talk about normalizing bodies of all
shapes and sizes we talk about how
the industry still hasn't made curvy
clothes that go
designer clothes that go up in sizes and
also balancing being a mom and a
business woman
it is amazing to me actually the
american woman in this country
size 14 that's the average size for us
68 close to 70
percent of women or a size 14 yet you
still that's still not what you see in
fashion magazines
it must make you want to naturally
powder yeah
yeah it's it's really sad and it's
heartbreaking but
also it that's what brings me passion
and drive to continue doing what i do
i talk about my body every single day
and i do it because of
the thousands of young people who don't
have role models who have cellulite on
their arms or back fat
that isn't normalized in the media and
it needs to be normalized
designers also need to have more
education in their school system
to understand how to make clothes for
bigger sized women that are designer
there's a lot of different issues here
actually it's anthony you say
in the wall street journal interview at
this point my skin is so thick
and i have dealt with so many people
just basically saying we don't have that
for her how did you how did you decide
to fight this
and and how have you fought it so
successfully
well first of all thank you for saying
that second of all i've
i've been criticized my whole career
again it's been 21 years of saying i'm
too fat i'm too thin i'm too loud i'm
i'm too everything that people want me
to be or not want me to be and
one time someone told me on social media
stop
making fat look cool you're going to
kill somebody
and that's when it hit me that i need to
continue
to create change for a younger
generation and i also understood what
affirmations were
your words have power your words can
dictate
life or death and i'm so glad that i
understood that and
affirmations for me are key especially
getting through those hard times with
people on social media
so you said that you are now talking to
a therapist because you're juggling
being a new mom
not a new wife a business woman and that
now you've
you decided that you need to seek out
help from a therapist what did you need
help in c
what did you need help for specifically
ashley if you don't mind sharing
no it's fine i think 2020 was really
hard for a lot of people
not only did we have the pandemic i
became a new mother
me and my family were living in nebraska
under my mother's roof
all together and i had a lot of
questions about
who am i and how can i still be a
businesswoman and a mother and a great
wife and
i didn't find it to be a problem to go
and ask for help and
i really encourage others to ask for
help when you need it especially during
these uncertain times
you know it took me 12 years to use to
lose my baby weight
so i'm wondering have you set a goal you
set a goal for yourself to say look i
got to get down to x number
are you saying forget the number it
doesn't matter
gail i'm so glad that you keep it so
real on social media because you make me
feel so much better and
i thought that it would just all fall
off if i was breastfeeding but that
is it doesn't and you know what i've
realized that my body is my body i've
still got
20 extra pounds on me and i am loving
all of it that's because you look so
good ashley graham it's always good to
see you
always good my best to you in your
pocket gail
bye